good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this tuesday morning more families have
had their holidays cancelled with staff
shortages at airports causing long
queues missed flights and ruined
half-term getaways gatwick manchester
bristol and stansted airports have all
been affected by the disruption trade
unions are warning that chaos could last
the entire summer and labour has accused
the government of being missing in
action i'll get their response in just a
moment
it's tuesday the 31st of may
ministers are urged to intervene to stop
holidays being ruined as airports and
airlines struggle to cope
and we're live here in dublin airport
where the irish government is demanding
answers after travel chaos saw a
thousand people miss their fights
also ahead the prime minister faces a
growing revolt as three more
conservative mps demand a vote of
confidence in his leadership
good morning i'll be live in ukraine as
russian forces march towards the center
of the strategically important city of
sierra donetsk
i'm live in brussels where eu leaders
have agreed a compromise deal to block
russian oil imports but only if it's
delivered by sea
orders an independent report into the
chaotic events before the champions
league final
[Music]
yep it is him johnny depp appears on
stage in sheffield and london's royal
albert hall as the jury considers its
verdict in the defamation trial between
mr jeff and his ex-wife amber hodge
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world i'm going to be
speaking to the former food bank user
turned campaigner that's j jack monroe
after new data shows just how much some
food prices have risen in the last year
[Music]
and getting the band back together for
the jubilee we'll be hearing from the
singing soldiers whose album outsold
whitney and michael jackson
[Music]
morning everybody long queues delayed
flights and cancelled holidays there
have been chaotic scenes at airports
right across the country with staff
struggling to cope and half term
getaways completely ruined trade unions
are blaming airports and airlines for
cutting too many jobs during the
pandemic they warned that the disruption
could last all summer
joining us now from ireland is uh
stephen murphy he is in dublin for us
this morning hundreds of people miss
flights because they couldn't even get
into the airport um hello to you steven
tell us more good morning
morning k from dublin airport it's more
than hundreds actually was at least a
thousand people missed their flights
here on uh sunday that was the worst day
of the delays that we have seen so far
and it reflects upon the pattern that
we've seen at airports uh right across
the uk and also in europe and places
like amsterdam as well and that is
essentially airports have been caught
out by the incredible recovery in travel
numbers since covet
restrictions fell away so here in dublin
airport for example where it actually
isn't too bad so far this morning a lot
of these queues have actually eased
since we arrived a bit earlier on uh
travel numbers are approaching 95
percent of pre-covet figures but the
staffing level after hundreds of staff
were left uh go during the pandemic is
only at 70 so we saw a real chaos here
over the weekend and this coming weekend
here at dublin in in ireland is a bank
holiday so there's real concern and the
management here at dublin airport have
today been given a deadline of this
morning to present an emergency plan to
the irish government the irish
government expressing its extreme
frustration and disappointment at the
scenes we saw this is a capital city
this is a major european travel hub and
the airport on sunday had to tweet there
was hundreds of people queuing outside
the terminal buildings telling them
you're going to miss your flight it's
unprecedented scenes and we have seen
that reflected in places like gatwick
and bristol and manchester as you say
plans thrown into utter disarray over
staffing levels and airports simply not
being able to cope by the amount of
people turning up
and it really has cast a poll of
uncertainty over travel plans for so
many families okay as we head into
summer okay thanks very much thank you
steven
should we chat about it with the
minister lord parkinson hi thanks for
joining us what's the government going
to do about this travel chaos well the
colleagues of the department of
transport are working with the industry
we have been for uh many months urging
them to make sure they've got enough
staff so that thanks to the success of
the vaccine rollout as people are able
to travel again that people can take the
holidays that they've missed and that
they've deserved and of course
it's causing a lot of distress for
people particularly in half term people
with family and children with them it's
very distressing if you turn up at the
airport and your flight isn't ready so
we've been saying to the industry that
they need to prepare for this they need
to have the staff that uh
that they need to make sure people can
get away and enjoy holidays but they
haven't got them no uh and we've been
using some of our post-brexit freedoms
to make sure that people can uh be hired
more quickly uh but this is sometimes
the industry
but well yeah but uh but in some of the
uh the regulations uh you know can be uh
met but can be met speedily but we've
been saying to the industry for quite
some time they should have been
preparing for this they say it's your
fault um i remember actually uh the
ryanair boss michael o'leary was on the
show quite a lot actually he said uh the
government support for airlines during
the corona virus pandemic had been
lamentable uh well there's a lot of
opinionated people in the aviation uh
industry but we've been working with
we've been working with people across
the the sector to make sure that uh they
were preparing for the reopening
of the economy and of travel after the
uh the pandemic abated we've been on a
long pathway back to recovery so that
people can enjoy this moment and the
company should be making sure that
people are able to get away on holiday
and enjoy it fully he said along with
others that you should have done more to
help them at the time and then they
wouldn't have to have got rid of as many
staff as they did well we've been
helping people across the whole economy
with support for jobs but of course the
pandemic hit lots of sectors in lots of
different ways there was a period when
uh people just simply weren't able to
travel for obvious reasons but there's
been many months where we've been back
on the uh the track particularly since
the vaccination uh to this moment and
the industry should have been recruiting
people
before that ready yeah so it's their
fault well no it's uh it's uh
well the company should have had the
people in place and we're working with
the colleagues of the department of
transport to make sure that uh they can
get people in as swiftly as possible is
there anything more that the government
can do now though to help because a lot
of people who are watching us at home
this morning will be thinking i don't
know if i'm going to go on holidays i'm
not spending 14 hours in the airport
with the kids what should i do well a
company should be making very clear to
people what they can do some are saying
make sure you get to the airport in good
time so we need clear communication from
the companies to the people that are
traveling and the colleagues of the
department for transport are working
with the industry to make sure that
they're getting people in as swiftly as
they can but you accept that people
standing outside over the airport trying
to get in is just not an acceptable
scene
is there anything more that the
government can do well we need more
people uh working working in the sector
and say we're using our post-brexit
freedoms to make sure that we can
recruit people as swiftly as possible
but they're you know that's for the for
the companies who but it does take three
months to train to get the necessary
security arrangements in place doesn't
it so it looks as though it's going to
carry on for a while yeah well we've had
a particular um uh
busy period this week with with half
term people wanting to get away but the
industry needs to be reacting to that
and getting people in as quickly as
possible and communicating clearly to
people traveling i know people who've
been caught up in it as well it's very
distressing people you know people need
clear communication need to know what to
expect when they get to the airport but
of course they also need to be able to
get away on the the holidays that
they've booked i certainly do um let's
talk about um the pressure on the prime
minister you were theresa may's advisor
um when there was a vote of no
confidence hinner back in 2018. what was
it like in the weeks leading up to that
uh well there's an awful lot of
speculation about the numbers of letters
that go in and past experience shows not
just then but uh before the only person
that knows how many letters that have
been sent in is the chairman of the 1922
committee and it's pretty pointless to
speculate about about the numbers uh
before then it's a it's a distraction
from the the work of government and in
government we're getting on with making
sure that we grow the economy to help
with the cost of living the question is
what was it like when uh theresa may in
the weeks before realizing that she had
to have this vote of no confidence it
must be a very stressful time um well
there was an awful lot for the
government to be getting on with then
just as there is uh now and she focused
on it just as the prime minister's
focusing on the things that matter now
the cost of living making sure that
we're providing the leadership we need
in the face of the uh war in ukraine uh
this it's pointless speculating uh about
something unless or until it happens
what's the relief like afterwards when
you've won the vote uh well it allowed
us to get back on with the things that
mattered then but uh well we'll cross
those bridges if and when we come to
them i mean there's a lot of criticism
um piling up for the prime minister we
at sky news understand 27 mps have
publicly called for the pm to go some of
the papers are suggesting it's um 29 as
you said there's only one person that
knows the exact number but it does feel
as though the rebellion is growing well
as it is it's pointless only so graham
brady knows uh how many letters are sent
and it's just important that across
government we're focusing on the things
that matter at dcms that's uh the happy
news of announcing the new city of
culture uh winner which we're coming on
coming out this evening yep want to know
more about that in just a second but let
me talk about jeremy wright attorney
general under david cameron um i think
under theresa may as well i'm writing
saying um you know he's saying it's time
for the prime minister to go carl les
the conservative leader of north
yorkshire county council which i think
is um sunak's uh constituency or
certainly covers that area also saying
it's time for him to go how are you
going as a government just to
to reassure these people that the prime
minister is the right person for the job
well the prime minister's taken
responsibility he's apologized for what
went on in number 10 he's made some
changes to the operation there uh so
that people can see that a difference uh
is being made and he is redoubling his
efforts to focus on the things that
matter to people the cost of living the
war in ukraine why is it not working
then why are they still handing in their
uh notices their letters to the 1922
committee and your colleagues well it
says it's for colleagues in the house of
commons to decide what they want to do
in the house of lords that doesn't
affect us we do we don't write letters
to the
chairman of the 22 but across government
everybody is focusing uh on the things
that matter uh to to people making sure
they can get away on the holidays making
sure that there's help with the the
rising cost of living making sure that
the economy is growing that we're
getting people into uh into good jobs
clearing the backlogs in the nhs because
of the coronavirus pandemic and that's
sort of thing that people want us to be
focusing on yeah city of culture tell me
about that
so we've had the largest ever
competition 20 places a bid to be the
next city of culture in 2025 coventry is
just finishing its year as city of
culture and is a great example of the
difference that it can make it's had
172 million pounds worth of direct
investment as a result of it and 500
million pounds worth of wider
regeneration but more importantly it
gets people uh back out and enjoying
the community meeting their neighbours
trying new things supporting the high
street and that's particularly important
as we're emerging from the economy
culture can be such a central uh way of
helping regeneration and or recovery
from the pandemic should we play a quick
game yeah okay um
imperial measurements i have not done
this yet this morning how many ounces
are there in a pound in the uk 14
16 16.
oh should i ask you another one go on um
if you ordered a pound of sausages
approximately how many grams of sausages
are you getting 250 350 450 or 550 if
you order a pound of sausages
approximately how many grams of sausages
are you getting
oh i know
i i was gonna say i would say 350 you're
saying 250 let me see
uh question seven it's upside down at
the bottom it's actually four fifteen
both wrong on that one uh which is more
this is the last one which is more four
pints or three liters
four pints or three liters three liters
i'd say three liters question nine
upside down this way question nine yay
yeah
so we'll find out this evening we do
yeah okay fantastic it's great to see
you thanks for playing along
uh still to come on the program we'll
tell you what's happening as far as the
papers are concerned the eye describes
the threat to boris johnson's political
future as growing by the day with
speculation mounting that the number of
letters of no confidence submitted may
now be nearing the threshold to
a vote
for the leadership excuse me
the guardian hears that the prime
minister's shift towards more overtly
right-wing policies in recent days is
what has prompted the backbench unrest
the mail leads with concerns from
ministers that the cost of living crisis
has pushed the cost of filling the
average family car with diesel to more
than a hundred pounds
metro reports on massive airport queues
over the half-term school holidays
delays which are expected to continue
into the jubilee weekend
that's also the lead story in the times
which reports that the government is
becoming increasingly angry with
airports and airlines
still to come on the program for you in
the next hour i'm going to be speaking
to labour's shadow financial secretary
james murray
as travel chaos continues across uk
airports we'll speak to one of the
thousands of people who've had their
flights cancelled
[Music]
and later this hour speaking to an
artist who's captured summer of queen
elizabeth's
most iconic moments through pop art
paintings to celebrate the platinum
jubilee
now after weeks of debate the european
union has agreed on a compromise deal to
block some russian oil imports in
ukraine itself russian forces enter the
strategically important city of seville
next in the east of the country joining
us now siobhan who is in brussels where
that announcement was made last night
and also ali who is in kiev for us this
morning alistair to you first of all the
ladies from where you are good morning
good morning kay well as you said uh the
town of several donetsk which probably
up until about a week ago most viewers
wouldn't have heard of has now become
one of the key battlegrounds
in the east of ukraine it is a railway
hub
but
now it is the priority for russian
forces uh sergey lavrov the russian
foreign minister said as much uh in the
last 24 hours the reason
why it is so important for russian
forces to capture it
is because it will help them knit
together their various movements in
eastern ghombas and they will have
captured the entirety of the luhansk
region to add to the donetsk region and
so they've concentrated a lot of their
forces in trying to take several donetsk
they have been thwarted by ukrainian
forces to be honest we probably thought
that it would have fallen by now it
hasn't the regional governor says that
ukrainian forces will stay and they will
fight but it is becoming street by
street we understand this morning
russians have started to make progress
towards the center of the city so
perhaps the resistance might only have
hours left uh before the russians do
fully take it but it is becoming a very
very brutal bloody battle most of the
buildings well in excess of 90 now
destroyed and it is becoming something
akin to what we saw in mariupol
okay thank you and let's bring in
siobhan as well tell us more about the
announcement that was made last night
good morning
morning k yeah well we thought it might
not happen yesterday very negative uh
words on arrival at the leaders
conference here yesterday but finally
late last night there was this agreement
in principle from the leaders that will
bring in a ban on russian oil imports
now the important detail is that this
will be
imports being brought in by sea and that
means it's essentially a concession for
hungary we've always had concerns about
this have been blocking it for the last
three weeks or so because they're
worried that they
are landlocked they very much rely on
oil coming from russia coming through a
pipeline so at the moment they're going
to get an exemption from that this will
still have an effect though this uh the
set of sanctions once it comes into
place will mean that there's a ban on
rational imports hitting around 90
percent of imports that come to the eu
by the end of the year and that's going
to have an impact of course on the money
that goes into vladimir putin's coffers
the money that he uses currently to fund
uh the war in ukraine just to underline
though this isn't the only thing that
they've talked about there are also
going to be
sanctions on three state broadcasters as
well on key individuals and also taking
the largest russian bank off the swift
system
okay thanks very much indeed uh both of
you much appreciated
uh we've just heard actually that
russian forces are pushing into the
eastern ukraine city of several donetsk
sky news has joined the ukrainian 93rd
brigade nearby the unit is preparing for
a long deployment in the donbass
our special correspondent alex crawford
has this report from the front lines
near isiam in eastern ukraine
this is what the russians have a lot of
and which the ukrainians want to see
more of and they say will make all the
difference in the war we've got to move
quickly now
they have to get out of the area because
they know the russians will be looking
to fire on this position and obliterate
the crew
this is what they're up against
the ukrainian government says this shows
the russians using thermobaric bombs on
the donbass
this is what the most horrific war of
the 21st century looks like the
statement said
the ukrainian troops on the front line
are horrifyingly exposed having to
defend large stretches of open land and
keep an enemy at bay who they are rarely
close enough to see
the russians are using their long-range
artillery to constant devastating effect
the smoke that you can see there shows
the russian positions as a village which
is half controlled by the ukrainians and
half by the russians
chief is asking his troops what the
situation's like there they've been
shelled an hour or so earlier
this small band of men have been holding
this position for weeks now
coming under constant attack every few
hours from russian positions
oh here we go end law they proudly show
us some of the foreign weapons which
have helped so far where's this one from
it's from britain
they're designed to destroy tanks at
short range with a single shot and they
need little training to operate
but here in the forest and farmland its
capability is limited ivan tells us
in this position it isn't that effective
he says because their tanks don't come
closer than three and a half kilometers
and this weapon can't reach the target
at that distance effectively
they need long-range artillery and tanks
themselves he says if they're to stop
this reinvigorated russian invasion
yeah you can see them in the distance
they've had some crucial successes
though recently somehow managing to stop
several russian tanks from crossing the
dam just in front of them and planting a
ukrainian flag to emphasize this
territory is still very much theirs for
now
well that's our special correspondent
alex crawford on the front line with the
93rd brigade you can watch the full
version of her report on our website at
skynews.com and also on our youtube
channel
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now though and uefa
have ordered an independent report into
the events surrounding the champions
league final french authorities have
defended police for firing tear gas and
pepper spray at liverpool supporters
blaming fraud on an industrial scale
liverpool chief executive billy hogan
has said it is completely inappropriate
for the french authorities to be forming
conclusions so early on
the government's terminated an agreement
with piano ferris in response to the
firm's sacking of nearly 800 seafarers
without notice replacing them with
cheaper agency workers the home office
said piano's contract with the border
force agency would come to an end with
immediate effect
the canadian government has introduced
legislation that would put a freeze on
importing buying or selling handguns
canada already has plans to ban 1500
types of military-style firearms and
offer a mandatory buy-back program that
will begin at the end of the year
austerity policies have had a
substantial contribution to the
stagnation of life expectancy in the uk
that's according to new research
throughout the 20th century life
expectancy grew year on year but began
to stagnate around 2012. researchers in
glasgow say government cuts were in part
to blame
a further 71 monkey pox cases have been
detected in england according to the uk
health security agency
this brings the total number of
confirmed monkey pox cases in england to
172.
now
how do you go about building britain's
biggest railway bridge we've got the
answer for you
can he fix it yes he can shiny is with
us good morning shingi tell us more
well you might say something about my
new get up
so this behind me is essentially a
bridge building machine or a launch
girder it is 160 meters long and it
weighs 700 tons and it's being used to
build what is unsurprisingly going to be
the largest railway bridge in the
country i'll step out so you can take a
closer look at it so this will be used
to lift giant concrete segments which
you can see there already a couple some
of them are in place a hundred and they
weigh 140 tons each and they'll form the
arches of the bridge keeping them in
position it will be made up of a total
of 100 concrete segments and like i say
when it will be completed which is
scheduled for two years away it will
form a part of the longest railway
bridge in the uk stretching between west
london and parts of the m25 so it's a
key cog in what will eventually be hs2
that is a project which obviously has a
lot of questions around it from the cost
now it could cost up to or close to 100
billion pounds which is over budget it
was originally scheduled to cost about
55.7 billion pounds and there was
obviously the recent controversy about
parts of hs2 being scrapped as well the
east midlands to leeds link being one of
those and other parts of the northern
element but when you look at things like
this you do think about crossrail part
of which was completed last week and
just the country's appetite for big
interesting infrastructure projects
which make travel easier across the
country and this is a key part of what
will be another one of those
okay for now thank you
johnny depp's turned up on stage at a
gig in london just a night after doing
the same in sheffield
[Music]
amazing the actor appeared unannounced
with jeff beck right now the jury is
considering its verdict in the
defamation trial between mr depp and his
ex-wife amber hood
quick look at the weather
[Music]
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we're in for a showery few days but
it'll turn mostly fine to end the week
there's a chance of more unsettled
conditions in the south on sunday quite
cool out of town with some mist and fog
island and northern ireland are mainly
dry
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now a new study has suggested that a
moderate coffee habit could cut the risk
of an early death by up to 31 research
using data on more than 171 000 people
find those enjoying a couple of cups of
coffee per day lived longer than
non-drinkers the apparent health
benefits were present whether or not the
drinks were sweetened with sugar
how'd you take your
coffee let me know do you like one of
those fancy coffees or do you just like
instant tweet me if you'd like to at k
burley we'll share some of them what
does that say mock or something uh how
do you like yours let me know we'll
share it with the world now in case you
woke up this morning wondering how much
the world's largest jaffa cake weighed i
can tell you it's 80 kilos or 176 pounds
in old money
should have tested the minister on that
uh former great british bake off winner
francis quinn has baked the world's
largest jaffa cake for a second time
beating her own world guinness record
set in 2017 the cake took
11 hours to make from start to finish
has a diameter of 175 centimeters or 69
inches and weighs the equivalent of more
than
606 000 rather 557 regular sized jaffa
cakes the only other question to ask
really is
why and these are pictures of the chaos
at the airports across the uk yesterday
holiday makers queuing for hours only to
be told that their flights had been
cancelled some fed up people at stansted
even took a little nap on the airport
floor i'm not sure that's a good idea
that in the daily express this morning
and this
golden doodle
a cross between a golden retriever and a
poodle was having a
positively
lovely time being carried by its owner
on the escalators at liverpool street
underground station in london no matter
what the size dogs must be carried on
tube escalators in case their fur gets
trapped one-way ticket to barking thank
you very much i'm here all week from
carrying a dog up an escalator to
climbing everest with a tiger this
wildlife photographer paul goldstein who
has just completed the everest marathon
the 59 year old wasn't alone though he
had his trusty stuffed tiger in tow
which he's also taken up kilimanjaro the
londoner has so far raised a hundred
thousand pounds for his worth more alive
charity ah that's why which aims to
protect
bengal tigers good for him
you wouldn't miss him in a crowd would
you uh now still come after the break
speaking to an artist who's captured
some of queen elizabeth's most iconic
moments through pop art paintings to
celebrate the platinum jubilee that to
come in just a moment to stay tuned
[Music]
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on sky news top
stories for you this morning travel
disruption continues across airports in
the uk and ireland with ministers urged
to intervene to stop holidays being
ruined as airlines struggle to cope
we've just heard from the minister on
this program who says the airlines
should have been better prepared
eu leaders have agreed to a compromise
deal to block russian oil imports paving
the way for tougher sanctions on moscow
more mps call for the prime minister to
resign over partygate with some
predicting boris johnson may be forced
into a confidence boat
one more on the travel disruption around
the country now earlier i spoke to the
arts minister lord parkinson he told me
the industry should have been preparing
for this a huge surge in travellers
leading up to the jubilee bank holiday
weekend
there's been many months where we've
been back on the uh the track
particularly since the vaccination to
this moment and the industry should have
been recruiting people
before they're ready yeah so it's their
fault well no it's uh it's uh well the
company should have had the people in
place and we're working with the
colleagues of the department of
transport to make sure that they can get
people in as swiftly as possible
tamara is here um you saw the minister
with the
with the imperial measure you're not
going to are you i am uh what is the
metric size of a standard bottle of wine
you should know
750 yeah you obviously
because you got it right
um how much is in a dram a sixteenth of
an ounce a sixteenth of a pec or a
sixteenth of an inch
um a sixteenth of an inch
no it's a it said it's a measure of
alcohol oh they'll have to keep them the
metric ones for me i think 16th of an
ounce
every day is a school day it certainly
is even for the minister it's
interesting what he was saying about
travel this morning indeed he was saying
that um the industry had months to
prepare for this they knew that when the
covered restrictions were lifted that
people would want to go on a
long-awaited holiday and that they
should have got the staff in place but
the industry say that you know it was
made very difficult for them they
couldn't keep people on furlough for
knocking on for two years of course
people would let go and they've
struggled to bring people um back in and
um they were in a difficult situation of
do they lay on way fewer flights or do
they have this awful situation where
people are having their flights
cancelled and having to sleep on airport
floors or not go away at all so um
government and industry sort of blaming
each other here but i think you know the
people losing out are of course holiday
makers and um
it doesn't look like certainly this half
term that any measures can be brought
forward and particularly to help people
better communication with those who are
going on holiday is something that's
obviously being called for and
as far as the votes of no confidence are
concerned well stephen parkinson of
course used to work for theresa may we
remember very well the day that the
letters threshold was met with theresa
may december 2018 and it looks like sort
of drip feed is turning into a steady
stream of letters going in calling for
uh boris johnson to resign the magic
number there is 54. now he said it's not
helpful to speculate on how near we are
because they're all secret only one man
knows how many there are and his name is
gray and brady but if they hit the
threshold of 54 and we know of 27 in
public and there's probably quite a few
more behind the scenes then what happens
there is a vote of confidence in the
prime minister and 180 conservative mps
half the party need to vote against him
in order to oust him so it's a pretty
high bar considering that almost that
many mps are ministers or ministerial
aides or in some way benefit from being
in boris johnson's government so those
who are putting the letters in will have
to consider
what happens if they get this vote they
then don't succeed in ousting him and
he's then safe for a whole year so um
the timing is going to be important for
for these rebels and it may be difficult
for them because unlike with theresa may
he would upset a particular faction the
brexiteers who are all working
coordination this doesn't feel very
coordinated there are letters coming out
of nowhere from different mps from
different areas of the country who don't
seem to have much in common with each
other
do we know
as soon as the 54th letter hits his desk
does he is he does he tell us then or
what happened so normally graham brady
who's the chair of the back benches
committee would say that the threshold
has been exceeded now parliament is in
recess in half term basically this week
so this doesn't normally happen in
recess so whether he could then hold on
until say
next monday when mps are back um in
order to have this confidence focus they
obviously need to be here for it to
happen we don't know exactly what the
process will be given it's in recess so
he may hold off for a few days but
certainly tory mps will be notified so
if anyone wants to take their letter out
at the last minute then they'll be able
to uh okay tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock looking for you then thank you
uh more now on the uh travel chaos and
the disruption impacting airports right
across the country let's speak to amanda
ferguson who's one of the thousands of
people whose flights were cancelled hi
thanks for joining us on the program
tell us what happened to you
good morning okay yes i understand that
there's more important things happening
in the world and we were among the lucky
travelers who was making their way home
uh but we arrived at gatwick on sunday
evening and we found out that we were
our flight was being cancelled because
our board impasses didn't scan so we
then spent uh roughly two hours on the
phone with easyjet trying to get to
dublin but they refused to put us on a
dublin flight with another carrier and
then they were going to send us to south
bend on sea to a hotel which would have
been a three-hour round trip onto our
journey so we booked ourselves into a
hotel that was near the airport and we
had a sort of layer head down for a few
hours then at about four in the morning
back to gatwick and we flew from gatwick
to glasgow and then from glasgow to
belfast and arrived home yesterday at
about lunchtime when we should have
arrived home on sunday evening
um
we've heard from easyjet they say that
they're very sorry
they say we've provided customers with
options to rebook including the
alternative carriers where no easyjet
flights are available or receive a full
refund etc etc hotel accommodation
available as well did you did you find
that they were being very helpful
well not particularly i felt sorry for
the growing staff because people were
particularly those who were heading away
and were very upset upset and angry with
them and i think that they handed us a
two-page document we tried to get on an
alternative carrier and refused we even
offered to pay ourselves and we're told
no and so then we came up with a sort of
planes trains and automobile uh version
did to get us back to belfast and i
think probably because i'm a journalist
it's probably the last person they want
in the middle of one of these sort of uh
events and you know
the staff on the ground were being as
helpful as possible but i think there
was a difficulty in communication with
the call center and that they didn't
understand why perhaps we wanted to get
to dublin because it was only 100 miles
up the road from belfast so it added a
bit of an adventure to our trip to to
london to see abba and and to brighton
and to see everything that was on offer
there uh but certainly i think my other
half being a very sort of uh chilled out
person and a cam person probably helped
me stay calm with this and you know as i
said we know that it's not the most
important thing going on in the world
but you really feel for people who were
traveling with toddlers who were
traveling with families who were missing
out on connecting flights that were
actually going to get them on their
holiday so after a 12 hour sleep um i'm
back in belfast and i have to now go
about filling in all the forms and
trying to claim all the the money back
for the hotel and all of that sort of
stuff
well you offered a replacement flight
because i think don't they have to offer
you an if somebody another airline is
traveling to the same place they have to
offer you a flight uh seat on that plane
well this this was the problem but
because we arrived on sunday evening we
were told that the next flight to
belfast was going to be on tuesday
evening and i said i'm not spending
another two nights in dublin and then we
said look there's an aerolingus flight
there that will get us into dublin can
you please put us on that and they
didn't which i think they might have
been incorrect in in refusing us that so
then they essentially said that they
could get us to another airport in
britain and then onwards to belfast so
the reason i picked glasgow is because i
used to live there as a student and also
because we thought well if there is
another cancellation between london and
glasgow at least if we can get into
scotland we can get the ferry back over
to northern ireland and back into
belfast so it was a roundabout way of
getting home but i do know that that
other people who stayed in the in the
hotel that we booked into uh were also
from belfast and they managed to get
them uh on a different belfast flight to
a different belfast airport so i don't
know what went wrong with with us on the
phone but uh we're back home now a
little later than anticipated and i just
hope that the process of of coming back
all of the the money that was put out
you know in advance is going to be
smooth sailing because i can't be
bothered with a lot of form filling and
i have several more hours on the phone
daisy did
yeah it's always a bomber for these
airlines when it's an eloquent
journalist that they take on good luck
thank you very much
thank you
from fishermen to pensioners food clubs
to family sky news is in plymouth this
week looking at the cost of living dan
whitehead investigates how rising fuel
and energy prices are affecting
businesses in the port city
for fish merchant ricky it's a 4 30 a.m
start every day
the fish he sells here in plymouth ends
up in restaurants across the country
but rising costs means cutting a deal
with fishermen and suppliers is getting
harder from the very beginning obviously
the boats have to
uh go out and catch it their fuel's gone
up
like i say double almost double uh so
therefore that's got passed on to us oh
bill's in here i've gone through the
roof we've got to pass on to our
customers we can't we can't absorb it
as you can tell everything's gone up
it's just ridiculous
for ricky bigger bills are leading to
some awkward conversations
the restaurants and hotels obviously
they're going to look for the best value
they can get at all times that's always
been the case
but now it's even more important
restaurants can't afford to staff can't
afford to run can't afford to open that
puts us out of business which there
on the on on the reverse hand puts
fishers out fishes in our business
what you realize is that everything is
linked catching these fish in plymouth
now costs more and it's not just us as
consumers who are having to pay it
impacts every business in the chain
we buy trays of eggs from a particular
local supplier they they used to be
three pound for a tray they've now gone
up to six pound so i'm having to go
somewhere else to source them at cafe
bene kerry serves up breakfast but he's
yet to pay herself a wage
with ingredients costing more and
cooking oil up 30
it's only a matter of time before price
is going
our breakfast all day breakfast is seven
pound they haven't gone up since we
opened the business so that is something
that we need to be looking at it's trial
and error i'm a bit scared actually to
be honest to to pass that cost on so at
the moment i'm sort of
keeping it where it is
why are you scared
because i don't want people to not come
in i've worked really hard nearly two
years to build this place and i'm
i'm afraid by putting the price up too
much people just will go elsewhere
dan whitehead's sky news in plymouth
now our next guest has put together what
they described as a love letter to queen
elizabeth the second
artist owen grahams in this high um has
painted a book capturing some of the
most iconic moments in the queen's life
through a pop art style biography with
key quotes from her majesty hi
okay you tell me about the book
so like you said in the introduction
it's a visual biography of her majesty
and i've created 27 artworks that span
her life
and tell the story of her life but also
in key moments that connect her life
with ours and how her reign
is intertwined with the history of our
our our lives okay so um
give me an idea of some of the artwork
that you have
portrayed and and how you chose those
particular subjects i think one that's
particularly poignant for me is
in
97 around the death of princess diana of
wales it was a really difficult time for
the the monarchy
and
cool
thank you thank you so for me there was
a point where the world was all turned
upside down and we were all so sad
because it was an enormous loss but when
the queen came to us on television and
said you know i speak to you now as your
queen and as a grandmother
that speech i think just hit us all in
the hearts and made us understand that
world event in a better way yeah and i
think she's done that over and over and
over again throughout her seven decades
yeah um other people
often
feel that they can't really connect
with royalty and particularly her
majesty um
what's your view on that when people say
always i can't i can't possibly
comprehend what sort of woman she would
be like yeah i understand that
completely because it is an abstract
relationship but it's a very significant
yet unique relationship that
relationship between sovereign and
subject
and the queen she's head of state
she represents us she is
she embodies i think the best of who we
are so that's how i tend to relate to
her and
what are your earliest memories of
my earliest memories were
i grew up in canada so i'm a child of
the commonwealth and back in the 60s
when i went to school at age five we
started primary school and every morning
we would begin the day by singing what
we call god save the queen in canada and
we'd stand by our desks and i would look
at the blackboards and above the
blackboards there was this beautiful
photograph of the queen and music came
through the loudspeaker and we all sang
this lovely song day in day out month
after month so i very quickly built this
relationship with this woman and i
learned
that even though i was growing up in
this wonderful you know tiny community i
was connected to a bigger broader world
and and an enormous and magnificent
history through the queen what's the
relationship like between canada and the
queen apparently it's the most visited
overseas country for her majesty
i think there's a i think there's a very
there's a huge love
for the queen in canada and it's been
really refreshing and exciting for me
with this book and through social media
so many people from my childhood have
contacted me
and then tell told me their stories and
how how they once saw the queen or how
as a new canadian as an immigrant they
she helped them belong so i think a lot
of people have similar stories to mine
and how this woman has been a unifier in
so many ways have you ever met her i
have not met her i've seen her when i
think it was 1976 she came to halifax
nova scotia that's a town where i grew
up and she came to
plant a tree and turn the soil for
a
ceremony at a veterans memorial hospital
so i remember that clearly and she was
sort of shimmering in her beautiful mint
outfit in the fog and halifax oh wow so
you have this mystical memory yeah i
mean that memory sort of
you know
is covered by the mists of time but it's
this beautiful
sort of moment and i was there with my
mom and so it was just a nice day and
what are you expecting and hoping for
this weekend
well i hope to get down to the trooping
of the color and to the pageant and just
sort of be part of the energy because i
think what's really
beautiful especially for me someone
who's newly british i became a british
citizen in
2021 so to be part of thank you so to be
part of this event and to be amongst
my fellow patriots
it's it's going to be a really beautiful
experience yeah and you're most looking
forward to tripping the colour i think
so i don't know
because we hope that she'll be on the
balcony we don't know yet yeah we're
really hoping
that that's the case well you can watch
it on skype definitely yeah there's a
fantastic pageant that's planned uh for
the sunday afternoon uh that um reflects
on her 70-year reign so it's going to be
just amazing sadly she's not going to be
out trooping the colour but she is going
to be represented i think uh by princess
the princess royal i think i think i
think i think i think i think nice and
saying that so it's going to be me and
then all the beacons of course i'm
giving it all away i'm giving it all
away it's lovely to see this is what
i'll be doing
the queen is about to celebrate her
platinum jubilee
something that no other monarch has done
that's 70 years of duty dedication and
service
sky news will bring you the celebrations
and pageantry to mark this historic
occasion plus
a very special guest
i'll be joining the sky news team as we
celebrate the very best of britain and
we cannot wait that's the platinum
jubilee on sky news
[Music]
yes seven o'clock on thursday morning i
will be outside buckingham palace and
probably be there until sunday evening
or thereabouts with a
quick sojourn over to um saint paul's
cathedral as well for the service of
thanksgiving you'll watch it all of
course here on sky news now the number
of menopause discrimination cases in uk
job courts are on the rise with the
government set to soon publish a
workplace menopause inquiry claire
hattrick is with us now she owns a
website which guides and supports women
through the menopause hi thanks for
joining us claire it's great to see you
um i'm so pleased that people i mean you
had to be anonymous really um when it
came to the menopause as soon as you hit
the menopause people women thought that
was it it's all over and it's so not the
case
it absolutely isn't it's it's
frightening how much it it personally
hit me i've probably lost about nine
years of my life to horrendous joint
pain now
um i set up clipboardclaire.com in july
2020 being an out of work beauty
therapist due to covid uh with the love
and support of my daughters abby and
beth one's a biochemist the others a
london paramedic and they said mum
you need to give your joints a break and
you've got this passion for helping
other women and making sure that nobody
else loses years of their life um to
menopause like i have
uh very quickly i took over a facebook
group and realized there was a big gap
in the market for a menopause help book
so
i think you've got that book kay but we
we self-published a menopause help book
which is very simple and written um and
aimed at men and businesses so it's a
few pages per symptom um i don't think
anybody's going to read um four 500
pages of book if they can just pick up a
book and and glance at it but it's
definitely something that we need to get
out in the community we need to start
talking about this and businesses and
men need to be on side as well it's
incredibly debilitating women um
you know are affected with brain fog
it's not just the physical symptoms it's
the mental ones as well
i know you're a big advocate of this as
well okay
and we love it that anybody is
championing and talking about this um
and the news have been absolutely
brilliant and you guys have been really
behind us and it's so important with the
hrt shortages it's debilitating for
women and we really need to get this uh
you know this these shortages sorted out
i know i'm still finding that that
ladies are contacting me through
clipboardclaire.com every day saying i
still can't get my gel pump i'm
panicking what do i do
um it's coming through slowly through
the system but but not quickly enough um
i know caroline knocks and carolyn
harris mps have got an all-party group
where they're they're really trying to
push
um you know the government to look at
women's health in a bigger and broader
sense
well it doesn't stop you talking claire
does it that's for sure
talk to me about what
talk to me about what businesses um
should do i'm lucky that that sky is is
very positive when it comes to menopause
and helping women through the menopause
and we have um we have working groups
that that help other women so that we
can we can talk about it and talk about
symptoms and the like but not every
business is like that
they're not i think the more it's talked
about i think businesses realize that if
the government are going to roll out a
basic menopause policy i think they
realize that they're going to have to
get on board it's going to be simple but
i think if you want to keep women in the
workplace there are a potential 1
million women k that could leave and
walk out of their jobs and and think
they've got brain you know they've got
brain fog and they think they've got
dementia i think if we can keep women in
the workplace it's good for your mental
health and why should women who've
worked incredibly hard work walk away
from their jobs exactly that what what
are your top tips
my top tips head over to clipboard
claire it's it's really good there's
small blogs that are aimed at men and
businesses as well as informing women
it's important i'm now running menopause
safer sessions to get the chat going and
i think if we can make it the norm
i think we'll be halfway there and i
think it's very long overdue okay very
long overdue it's the embarrassment as
well isn't it i mean i i i remember when
i first started suffering from symptoms
of the menopause i was really
embarrassed and when i knew a hot flush
was coming it made it worse because i
was embarrassed about it as well so i
think by talking about it especially to
younger people men and women then you
become less embarrassed that's always my
top tip what's yours
yeah i think if we can i think women who
suffer with vaginal dryness i've got
friends that can't sit can't stand can't
walk and less than 10 of women go and
get help for it i think if everybody
understood it and realized that it's not
you know you're not on your own i think
you know that would be absolutely great
again it's just getting education is key
if we can start in schools and roll it
out you know across businesses it would
be the norm and and you know society
would be wonderful wouldn't it we'd all
be menopause friendly
exactly that it's great to talk to you
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us this morning claire really
appreciate it
thank you
thanks a lot
yeah just chat about it quick look at
the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we're in for a shower a few days but
it'll turn mostly fine to end the week
there's a chance of more unsettled
conditions in the south on sunday
it's quite cool out of time with some
mist and fog island in northern ireland
are mainly dry but britain has
widespread showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we've been talking about imperial and
metric measurements this morning um if
you go to my twitter feed at k burley
you can find out how the minister got on
on our little quiz also pictures there
of the chaos at airports across the uk
yesterday holiday makers queueing for
hours only to be told that their flight
had been cancelled some fed up people at
stansted
even took a nap on the floor don't do
that
but we have got a happy picture for you
look at this golden doodle it's a cross
between a golden retriever and a poodle
he was having a positively
fantastic time being carried by its
owner on the escalators at liverpool
street underground station in london no
matter what their size dogs must be
carried on tube escalators in case their
fair gets trapped i've already done the
barking line so i'm certainly not going
to do it
again what i am going to do is pause for
thought and i'll see you in just a
couple of minutes time top of the hour
please stay tuned our way
[Music]